hey what's up welcome everybody so in
this video we are going to build a chat
application using villages and firebase
so the main goal of this video is to
help you get started with five ways
especially file store so you can use
that as your back-end for your view
application alright so let's get started
by creating new view project so we need
to create a new project using view CLI
so in your system you see allies should
be installed so if you create and name a
project I'll call it YouTube alright
whitey firebase you set so we'll
manually select features so you might
not see this first option so we'll need
okay we'll need this router just hit for
in your keyboard this is in for number
and we'll need few X we don't need
linter alright so that's it hit inter
use history mode for router ok yes what
if config for in yeah in dedicated
config files save this as a preset for
future no so it will create a new view
project so if you are new to view you
can go to view cast or home to learn
basic of view okay so once it got
installed let's CD into our just created
project and then we need to run NPM run
solve yeah while it is compiling let's
open up new tab
and we'll open the project in sublime or
you can use vs code so it got compiled
and put up this server at this location
control click to go to and let's see
yeah so this is the default application
with few router it can go to home about
alright so let's go to sublime and yeah
so this is our project structure we got
main component here and routes store and
main dot yes we got fuse over here and
necessary components over here so this
is a structure which comes with view
template so now what we'll do is we'll
create a front-end for outside
application so instead of creating that
I will I will use default template
available at this location yeah so boots
nib comm you can get different template
made on boot chef here so I will grab
the HTML from here I will create a new
view component so you can you can make
on this home or I'll create a new file I
will call it private jet dot view so
this is over here alright
copy some go from here to there alright
and we need to use this but we we don't
need everything we just need containers
so I'll just copy the container into my
newly created said component step down
alright so our private said component is
ready
we don't need name alright so once
private said component is ready we go to
router taught yes and then we import
this newly created component aimed
private set and we'll so we'll replace
home with our private side component
alright
so whenever you hit save you will get
updated code over here yeah so currently
we have no bootstrap 3 and we have a
sorry booster for and we haven't copied
CSS yet so let's copy them as well so
control a control C in to so we need to
create a styles as well style and scoped
for this component only and just paste
it
yeah better yeah also we need to import
which for so we we just need CSS we
don't need this so I'll copy this into
our index.html so index dot HTML is
inside public and here you need to
import your bootstrap CSS so I'll paste
it over here alright alright so now it
looks better alright so now that our
front-end layout is in place now we need
to make it dynamic so whenever we type
something here and hit save
we need to save this data somewhere so
in order to do that we need to set up
our firebase
so let's get started with five is if you
go too far with google calm here if you
get started it will give you a demo and
all so it will take you to your 5 s
console and here you need to create at a
new project so so I've couple up but
I'll create new for this one so you can
name it anything you want I will name it
you
cent okay so I asked that create project
all right so let's it continue and it
will take us to the dashboard related to
this project all right so far system is
to say as it is saying get started by
adding fire wish to your app so we need
to add five ways to our app so there are
a couple of option for iOS Android and
for web so since we are developing for
web if you hit this and you will get so
there are a couple of Sun you can import
like this or you can use doing from
using NPM so if you go to this get
started with firebase for web app you
get this information so we will install
our using NPM so let's go to our
terminal install firebase and alright so
once firebase is installed let's go back
to our project and you know this time
we'll just copy sorry here so just copy
it into your
into your main dot yes and here we'll
we'll have this config variable with all
our configuration and then we'll
initialize it into five is so before
that we need to import five ways right
import firebase from firebase all right
so now virus is initialized and next
step is to so since we are using the
database so we'll be using this database
so there are two of some cloud file
store and real time database yeah these
two options so clarifies PI stories in
beta it is new so we'll use this one
faster so we start in test mode enable
our so our file store database created
so if you want you can go to Docs and
get started with it and store it for web
and over here cloud file store get
started
so it will give you step-by-step
information so you don't need to do that
we already installed firebase we require
how okay we require firebase so we also
underscored this as well and then we
need to install we already initialize
this and let's add these two as well so
we initialize that app and so we created
this TV and then we do this so otherwise
you will get some warning in console so
this will disable them so we created
this variable DB and will use this
variable to access our database alright
so we'll be using this TV variable from
our other component you can import that
there or you can assign this to window
variable so that it will be accessible
from anywhere yeah you can do that or so
once that is done our firebase setup is
complete we don't need to do anything
now our next step is to add data to our
database when user enters something and
it inter ok so in order to add data to
our database what we'll do is we have
this simple input field and then we have
this button alright so this is our form
and we need to bind it to messes and
[Music]
we need to create that over here data
shootin object and messes by default
will be null
so whenever user types something it will
have some value and then we will submit
that so we'll submit on inter so on key
up dot enter well to save messes and
we'll create this methods a message so
we'll create that method over here
methods say messes alright so the way we
create data in our database is in Far
East or is so let's let's come into save
to fire store and here we need to send a
request to Phi store to save our data so
if you go to getting started section you
have this so you can save it like DB
then collection name where you want to
save and then call add method alright so
and the parameter that you want to save
and you get these callback are so let's
do that so let's do D B dot collection
and then collection name so we'll be
storing those messes in set so we'll
create that so it will automatically
create we just need to display here and
then we'll call add method and we need
to supply our object so we'll save like
this key value fail message is this
start message so this dot message is
this message over here
or so that's it so if you want to save
anything any other parameter there you
can certify here anything like so
alright so for now let's say message
let's go back to browser so here
whenever someone order so this is first
message and hit enter so let's go to
file store let's refresh so as you can
see here it successfully created a new
message so it created a collection named
it said that we specified it here and
then it created our field messes like so
so document is like a unique ID it
automatically generate this unique ID so
you can also specify if you want but it
will if you leave a blank it will just
automatically so this is our first
message so after I enter a message it
says persist here we need to clear this
field let's do that so after the message
is done let's make this dot message goes
to null all right other so this is the
saving part saving new message yeah
saving new messages and so we saved it
we need to pull the pull all messages
and display it here so instead of
showing this dummy data let's pull in
from firebase so to get data you just
need to reference the collection and
then look through each of them and
display it here like so
all right so let's do that so we will do
that on our created lifecycle so
whenever this component created we
create will fetch all messages this
start fetch messages let's create that
method first messages and we'll face
using DB and then collection name so we
are fetching from the shared collection
and then we need to do get so this will
get all messages and after getting
message well then what we'll do is so
you can name it anywhere queries
snapshot and then we'll look through it
for each data oh you can call it dark so
basically it will give us all the talk
over here like these doc then we'll look
through this talk and then get data in
that talk so that is how it works
so first we'll create a local all mess
faces very well empty and then we'll
push data there all messages start push
talk table data so this will be the
object so this object so it will return
exact this object and we'll push it to
all messages so after this loop is done
we'll assign this start messages equals
to all messages so we need to create
this messages data here property here so
message says all messages so this will
be the empty array and after it is done
it will have array op object of all
messages alright so that's it work let's
go to
browser open up inspector and on View
tab let's go to private said yeah so
this is component yeah see how it shows
anonymous component so I think if you
keep name property here it was so the
name let us keep it private surname save
it and there we go so as you can see the
message is not and messages there we got
to see this data is method so I was
doing mistake my bad sorry about that
yeah so now we get object of all
messages as Eddie so now we can easily
look through it and display it here so
let's do that next go to our private
search component and here we got all the
me messages let's catch it up them
mystery incoming message outgoing let's
get rid of it so let's give on the one
and then we look through all right
go through it v4
masses in masses and here will display
the masses so we'll have access to
messages object so this will be the
object and inside this object we have
message property so message start messes
that should work let's get rid of the
same is let's keep it minimal yeah so we
can see all messages here new one so
currently it is not real-time we will
make it in a moment
we need to refresh the page and we
should see yeah new one over here so as
you can see it is not ordering by the
time at the same time so we need to
order that by time as well
so let's handle that first so in order
to order them by time we need to so
while facing we need to order by but the
problem here is we are not saving the
time when we created this message so
here we are the saving message let's
save a new property as well named
created at and this will be the new date
so new date will be the date of creation
like it will be the current date like
now yeah so anak and now if we create a
new message will have this created at
property there and before getting we can
do order by order by created at all
right but you know what we need to clear
up our database to start up because that
will throw error because we have no
created at yet
so let's clear everything and start from
scratch
refresh so brand-new messes refresh yeah
hi man so there we go so hymen is only
more recent all right so at least say it
is working so now we need to make it
real time because we have to hit inter
and refresh every time to see new
messages so to make it real time instead
of doing this so here we are facing
message right so instead of doing the
get what we need to do is we need to do
on snapshot so it will current
constantly listen for new changes so
yeah we don't don't need to do then
snapshot alright so on snapshot will
have exact same thing and we will be
doing exact same thing like previous so
now this will make it real time let's
taste it refresh to make everything
clear are also real time
there we go more messages aura so it is
working so we see how we confess the
message on real time so next thing what
we need to do is we need the name of
user who created the message right so
that way we can identify who created the
message so for that we need to make the
authentication system so luckily we
already have always got authentication
we don't need to do anything much so now
we need to make the login system so that
a user and on the user can only access
this space after logging in right so on
the authenticated user will access and
then create message then we'll store our
created message in our collection and
then we'll display it here alright so
now let's build authentication system so
for that let's do let's first create a
login component so what we'll do here is
so if you go to authentication there are
different method for our authentication
we have a different sign in method
available like so let's go to
authentication and then it's setup sign
in method also yeah so these are all
option available to us we can do using
email password form Google yes like this
so so now most of the people have Google
account so I'll make it simple will
enable the Google sign-in method and
then will allow user to sign in using
Google so just enable and save it so now
you can see Google enabled so we want
email password you can do that as well
all right so under authentication so you
can go through get started if you want
to do email and password and set up
login but in this video
we'll be using Google sign-in methods so
let's go to Google sign-in and we will
do exact same thing like first we need
to initialize the provider so we'll put
this code on our login component so
before that let's create our login
component so I'll duplicate this home
let's create a new file login dot view
we'll have simple template and let let's
put it please login to continue log in
with your Google to continue so and
we'll create here our button very simple
login with Google and when someone
clicks on this button will and - we'll
call this login method which will be
creating over here
methods and then matter name will be
login so here so first we need to
initialize the provider like so so
provider will be five is odd so before
that since we are using this five is we
need to import the five is here
import file piece from firebase and then
there is a dis optional step if you want
to do you can do like adding school
read-only so this is optional we won't
do that we want to skip that and here
comes the main stiff so now we need to
call this sign-in with pop-up and we'll
pass the provider that we just
initialized and it will open the pop-up
and ask you and do everything for you so
yeah so this is quite easy so we'll copy
this code into our component below here
and I will make it look a bit nicer so
sign in with pop and then after it
results returns result we will then do
this token if we need token then we will
yeah so currently we don't need to do
anything like so just leave that so this
bit of code will execute on success and
this bit of code on failure
so let's use es6 syntax result lecture
and then what what we'll do here is
after the successful login we will
redirect user to the login sorry the
main component alright so what we'll do
here is this start router dot push will
push it to home component so now our
login code is in place next we need to
create this route right so otherwise how
can we access that so login let's import
that dog in as well
login and then we'll create our new
route just duplicate it and I'll name it
login and it will be login there we go
so that is done let's go to our
application and let's see what we can
improve so login yeah please log in with
Google account to continue
totally fine let's hit login with Google
so ask us to sign in so since we are
running on HTTP and localhost it will
ask you to give you this warning thus
advanced and go to the firebase app and
allow yeah we trust it because it is our
own application nothing harmful going on
alright so it take took us to home
component alright so in this in this
window we are logged in and we can
access so we need to fix one more thing
so for example let's open up this on our
guest window where we
not logged in and if we try to go to our
homepage it's learned a lot right
because we are not not authenticated we
it need to take us to the login
component so that we have to login in
order to come here so to restrict the
unauthenticated users from accessing the
private side component we need to do we
need to create here before route inter
so the router method so below create 8
will create that so view router allows
this before route enter 4 enter method
this you can find this on documentation
for reference so it will just woke up
before everything like even even before
created it will get executed and here
we'll check if user is authenticated or
not so the way we do it is like so next
V M so the VM is like this so we do not
have access to this in this bit of block
of code because in this is even getting
a slight before this initialized and so
we access these variable or even the
router from using VM so next will be
executed after we return next from here
so for example let's see let me give you
example by doing it so we need to check
if we have
authenticated user or not so the way we
do in firebase is like this
firebase odd-odd state changed so this
will give us user if you as a result on
ticket of course so this is the method
on all the state chains it will give us
so you do it will taste tell us both if
you user logged in or if user loggers
basically if our changes like so for
example if there is user so if it
returns user we will will tell router to
go to the next request so it is just
like me to wear in laravel if you have
him there to it so if there is user that
means user is authenticated we will go
to next request which is it will allow
us to move next else if there is no user
then we will go to router so this router
dot push to login component so as I will
already mentioned we we have no access
to this there that's why we use VM so
basically this viewer order allows this
kind of method to access the this from
here there we go so now we are
protecting from on authorized access so
let's go to our guest window and let's
try to access it once more looks like we
missed something
yeah so we need to import this file ways
right so we missed that alright so once
that is turn
suppress yeah so whenever we try to
access the homepage it is taking us to
this login component cool so after we
login we should get to there's a will
retest at that no need to taste it now
we know now we need to do what we need
to do is we need to restore the
authenticated user in our variable named
let's call it out user yeah autism is
fine so by default it will be the empty
object and so whenever the component is
created so after component created we
will assign that here so here fire they
start odd so if user then we can do this
start user sorry to start odd user
equals to user all right so that's it to
else we'll make this start out user and
also for example if user logged out this
will fire of I can fire off because we
are concerned listening for autistic
chains and then we'll have access to
sorry
we'll make thought user null so we need
to store the information about who
created message as well so let's do that
here so I will call it author or message
okay author
so this start out user dot display name
so by the way this is the format so
author contains this display name UID so
if you console.log
can see that our I learned it from
documentation yeah so like here so we
got display name user email email verify
it
so these are our option that occurred by
default other so now that we are saving
all necessary information about message
so like message content author on
message and then created it so now what
we can do here is we can display the
author or message like so messy start
author also we can so messy start treat
it at but our yeah so this is the whole
object yeah so we'll use other momentous
to make it look nicer in a moment for
another sketch it out this and also
let's remove delete all documents will
you start over with author name as well
okay hi hello there we go
so if you log in with another user in
other window we can get that so let's
taste it alright so I'm logged in with
two different user over here and here
nurse said hey this
hi web tab there we go I can I can
listen you yeah all right so let's add
some special class depending open who
created the message to make it look a
bit nice so what we'll do over here is
so while looking through all messages we
need to find out who created so if the
user who logged in has created message
we'll apply the different style to that
otherwise we'll apply different style
all right so here we are looping through
all messages and we are applying this
class so we will toggle this class so to
do that use es allow us to dunham and
dynamically apply the class so the way
we do that is like so so we'll bind the
class by keeping the taught and and here
we'll supply this and we'll use the
ternary operator here so for example if
message taught author each equals to
user tour display name so so currently
users display name in author message
then we'll apply a one class sorry one
class
so then it will be the sent message
right so we'll apply this class
otherwise we'll apply received message
class so this is how we toggle clasp and
yeah so now we need to write CSS for
these two class over here to make it
look the way we want so we will make
sent message look one way and other look
another way so will not go through
styles yeah so I just applied different
color for them now let's see how it
works
each user sorry about that
so message dot author should match aught
user yeah like so so as you can see if
new my system it is not a scrolling all
the way down right so we need to fix
this scrolling issue so to do to fix the
scrolling it is quite simple so after
receiving new message we need to scroll
to all the way to bottom so to scroll to
bottom we need to create our new method
scroll to bottom let's create our new
method over here scroll to bottom yeah
so yeah I defined a simple variable box
and we are getting the box which
contains all message which is this
message history all right so it contains
all the messages and we are just
crawling to top all the way down like
box Tata straw height and we need to
call this scroll to bottom method after
someone's sent the message right so
after someone add the message we'll have
this 10
so after someone successfully sent the
message we'll just scroll to bottom I'll
call this method so this will fix when
someone types and hit enter also we need
to call this method
after receiving message right so after
we receive message we need to call that
as well so here we are doing that and
let's do set timer so we'll call this
method after some time because because
otherwise it takes some time to render
the data so without rendering it will
not a scroll to bottom right so we'll
make one one-second delay so if we call
this is scroll to bottom bottom without
pie not so these are messes won't get
rendered so this will call before this
I'll get rendered so this is quick fix
for that yeah so now it should scroll to
bottom there we go so let's try I am
typing some message there we go there we
go without doing anything yeah so this
is a simple chat application hope you
learned something about firebase heist
or how to use that to build simple
application